وامتازوا اليوم ايها المجرمون
الم اعهد اليكم يا بني ادم الا تعبدوا
الشيطان انه لكم عدو مبين وان اعبدوني هذا
صراط مستقيم
ولقد اضل منكم جبلا كثيرا افلم تكونوا
تعقلون
هذه جهن جهنم التي كنتم توعدون
اصلوها اليوم بما كنتم تكفرون
اليوم نختم على افواههم وتكلمنا ايديهم
وتشهد ارجلهم بما كانوا يكسبون
ولو نشاء لطمسنا اعينهم فاستبقوا الصراط
فانا يبصرون
ولو نشاء لطمسنا على اعينهم فاستبقوا
الصراط فانا يبصرون
ولو نشاء لمسخناهم على مكانتهم فما
استطاعوا مضيا ولا يرجعون
ومن نعمره ننكسه في الخلق افلا يعقلون
وما علمناه الشعر وما ينبغي له ان هو الا
ذكر وقران مبين
لينذر من كان حيا ويحق القول على الكافرين
اولم يروا انا خلقنا لهم مما عملت ايدينا
انعاما فهم لها مالكون
وذللناها لهم فمنها ركوبه
ومنها ياكلون
ولهم فيها منافع ومشارب افلا يشكرون
واتخذوا من دون الله الهه لعلهم ينصرون
لا يستطيعون نصرهم وهم لهم جند محضرون
فلا يحزنك قولهم انا نعلم ما يسرون وما
يعل نون
اولم ير الانسان انا خلقناه من نطفه فاذا
هو خصيم مبين
وضرب لنا مثلا ونسي خلقه قال من يحيي
العظام وهي رميم قل يحييها الذي انشاها
اول مره وهو بكل خلق عليم
الذي جعل لكم من الشجر الاخضر نارا فاذا
انتم منه توقدون
اوليس الذي خلق السماوات والارض بقادر على
ان يخلق مثلهم بلى وهو الخلاق العليم
انما امره اذا اراد شيئا ان يقول له كن
فيكون
فسبحان الذي بيده ملكوت كل شيء واليه
ترجعون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضال الين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصافات
صفا فالزاجرات زجرا فالتاليات ذكرا ان
الهكم لواحد
رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما ورب
المشارق انا زينا السماء الدنيا بزينه
الكواكب وحفظا من كل شيطان مارد لا يسمعون
الى الملا الاعلى ويقذفون من كل جانب
دحورا ولهم عذاب واصب الا من خطف الخطفه
فاتبعه معه شهاب ثاقب فاستفتهم اهم اشد
خلقا امن خلقناه انا خلقناهم
من طين لازب
بل عجبت ويسخرون
واذا ذكروا لا يذكرون واذا راوا ايه
يستسخرون
وقالوا ان هذا الا سحر مبين
ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا وعظاما اانا
لمبعوثون
اوباؤنا
الاولون قل نعم وانتم داخرون
فانما هي زجره واحده فاذا هم ينظرون
وقالوا يا ويلنا هذا يوم الدين
هذا يوم الفصل الذي كنتم
به تكذبون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الحمد لله
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله ظهر
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم الذينغ
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
அலைக்கும்
கle ஆரி
இன்ஷா அல்லாஹ
இடஸ்ஹலாடஷன்ல
30,000
‏by
cont
and plus the
things provide for the bing expes the
things that we are directly attbut to
‏arequ
and part of be are
some funds for the fam in our community
so we going do that comin you will have
option to on theck
how you want to distbute allocate the
funds
so again this fr fund raising is going
to be purpose one is for the covering
the expenses of
‏and take care of the need in our
community
and obly we are col that would like
pleasute to that as you can so distই ان
شاء الله جزاكم الله خي
[Silence]
بسم الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
ليله القدر
‏all
يوم عرفه
ليله القدر
عرفه
ليله القدران
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
ليله القدر
‏man
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
and unable to put
everyle of the last 10 ofضان
and ‏So for that
very limited amount of vitality if he
were to put it into any night which
should he put it into
the prophet
responded عليك 27
said then put
that effort into the 27th night.
‏Now if we look at this narration as is
can weason
understand
always on the 27th night can we conclude
that from this narration no can we
conclude that we should only
focus on one of the last 10 ofان
‏The most that can beed from this
narration
is if a person
to have limited capabilities as this man
did and he were to
put all of his you know hedge all of
his proverbial bets on one night.
What night should it be? He said the
27th night. ‏We could even understand
from this narration that that year only
it happen to be on the 27th night and
the prophet
that and told this compion this because
the convation wasn't every night of the
last 10 ofان in every year I can only do
one night so which of the last 10 should
I choose everyle year he asked him
[Silence]
‏in view
andes aroundate
صلى الله عليه وسلم التمسوها في العشر
الاواخر
ليله القدر
‏But that word is often misunderstood as
well
because it could be od with respect to
what is passed.
So with respect to what is passed it's
the 21st or the 23d or the 25th those
are the odd nights with respect to what
is passed.
Or it could be od with respect to what
remains.
صلى الله عليه وسلم
التمسوها على الوتر
ل 21
مضينا و3
مضينا و25 مضينا الى اخره
seek out of ليله القدر
لوتر بقينا لتسع بقينا لسبع بقينا لخمس
بقينا
‏that is on the night with respect to
what
nightsing
nightsing if it is
with respect so it's od with respect to
the the what is to come then it is even
with respect to what is the 2
of what is the 24th
ابن الاسق
احمد
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
ليله القدر
‏an
انزلناه
في ليله مباركه
انا انزلناه في ليله القدر
ليله القدر
واثله ابن الاسقله
وانزل القران لث
مضمضان
قران
2 night
ofان
that's
with respect to what with respect to
what is to come so if the month is 30
days long
it will be on with respect to what
and if the month is 29 days days days
long it is
with respect to what
‏are
how is
point not to
is not
the point of noted people would not
become la because you haveous it makes
everything around look is is
void
ليله القدر
much more
and
areal
andychology
prop عل
was
that would
ليله القدر
overtain
of القدر
among
القدر
التمسوها في العشر الاواخر من رمضان
ليله القدر
ليله القدر الله سبحانه وتعالى
gra
شهر
ليله القدر any
عائشه رضي الله عنها prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الحمد لله
‏compion our because we would suff
fromgidance
if our if ourors
not so and knowledable we will only be
as good as our
and so
bless this with the best of predecessors
who asked the best question and not only
that but theyed
عائشه رضي الله عنها صلى الله عليه وسلم
ليله القدر
صلى الله عليه وسلم ايش
[Arabic recitation]
تحب العفو فاعفو عنا
انك عفو كريم
كريم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
made
oftimes
spice
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏What does that mean overlyancy?
You are standing in front of Allah as a
slave before his
are to your attempt is to ody humility
and epitom it.
‏Wonder
vo you haveever
you are
not place
the best is thates
humility
that's the best and so the prop
made the best so we don't around with
اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عني
دعا
‏asateength
powerful
really we stand and make 15 20 25 minut
this is never the of propcept
‏first
is asking for a dr
the second instance is before war the
before
those are the two instances when he made
for a very long time with the rest of
the companion other than
عا اللهم ارحمنا واحنا واقفين وارحمنا
واحنا قاعدين وارحمنا واحنا جالسين
وارحمنا واحنا طالعين وارحمنا واحنا
نازلين وارحمنا واحنا على اليمين وعلى
الشمال ومن فوق ومن تحت وارحمنا واحنا
كبار واحنا صغار واحنا ذكور واحنا اناث
واحنا اللهم ارحمني
تسب
صلى الله عليه وسلمعا
ولذلك نهى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عن
السجع في الدعاء
اي السجع الذي يكون متكلفا
‏all
other unancy
you are
place
hum some comp
need to be they would put on
the wor and lowest cheapest of
theirthing
‏to humility in front of Allah. ‏some
dirt on fa
why to humility this is place that is to
a slave
so humble
won
heart that's what you're looking for
ان يتقبل منا وان يبلغنا ليله القدر نساله
سبحانه وتعالى الا يؤاخذنا بما فعل
السفهاء منا والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد ان شاء الله سنه صلاه
تراويح
[Silence]
استقيموا اعتدلوا استووا
سووا الصف سدوا الخلل
الله
اكبر
سبحانك الله
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
هذا يوم الفصل الذي كنتم به تكذبون
احشر الذين ظلموا وازواجهم وما كانوا
يعبدون
من دون الله فاهدوهم الى صراط الجحيم
وقفوهم انهم مسؤولون
ما لكم لا تناصرون بل هم اليوم مستسلمون
واقبل بعضهم على بعض يتساءلون
قالوا انكم كنتم تاتوننا عن اليمين
قالوا بل لم تكونوا مؤمنين
وما كان لنا عليكم من سلطان بل كنتم قوما
طاغين
فحق علينا قول ربنا انا لذائقون
فاغويناكم
انا كنا غاوين
فانهم يومئذ في العذاب مشتركون
انا كذلك نفعل بالمجرمين
انهم كانوا اذا قيل لهم لا اله الا الله
يستكبرون
ويقولون انا لتاركوا الهتنا لشاع شاعر
مجنون
بل جاء بالحق وصدق المرسلين
انكم لذائق العذاب الاليم وما تجزون الا
ما كنتم تعملون
الا عباد الله المخلصين
اولئك لهم رزق معلوم
فواكه وهم مكرمون
في جنات
النعيم على سرر متقابلين
يطاف عليهم بكاس
معين
بيضاء لذه للشاربين
لا فيها غول ولا هم عنها ينزفون
وعندهم
قاصرات الطرفعين
لانه
بيض مكنون
فاقبل بعضهم على بعض يتساءلون
قال قائل
منهم اني كان لي قرين يقول اانك لمن
المصدقين
ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا
وعظاما
انا لمدينون
قال هل انتم مطلعون
فاطلع فراه في سواء
الجحيم
قالت قالت الله ان كت لتردين
و ولولا نعمه ربي لكنت من المحضرين
افما نحن بميتين الا موتنا الاولى وما نحن
بمعذبين
ان هذا لهو الفوز العظيم
لمثل هذا فليعمل العاملون
اذلك خير نزلا ام شجره الزقوم
انا جعلناها فتنه للظالمين
انها شجره
تخرج في اصل الجحيم
طلعها كانه رؤوس الشياطين
فانهم لاكلون منها فمالئون منها البطون
ثم ان لهم عليها لشوبا من حميم ثم ان
مرجعهم
الجحيم
انهم
الفوا اباءهم
ضالين
فهم على اثارهم يفرعون
ولقد ضل قبلهم اكثر الاولين
ولقد ارسلنا فيهم منذرين
فانظر فانظر كيف كان عاقبه المنذرين
الا عباد الله المخلصين
ولقد نادانا نوح فلنعم المجيبون
ونجيناه واهله من الكرب العظيم
وجعلنا ذريته
هم الباقين
وتركنا عليه في الاخرين
سلام على نوح للمين
انا كذلك نجزي المحسنين
انه من عبادنا المؤمنين
ثم
اغرقنا الاخرين
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وان من شيعته لابراهيم
اذ جاء ربه بقلب
سليم اذ قال لابيه وقومه ماذا تعبدون
ائف الهه دون الله تريدون
فما ظنكم
برب العالمين
فنظر نظره في النجوم فقال ان سقيم
فتولوا عنه مدبرين
فراغ الى الهتهم فقال الا تاكلون
ما لكم لا تنطقون
فراغ عليهم ضربا باليمين
فاقبلوا اليه يزفون
قال اتعبدون ما تنحتون والله خلقكم وما
تعملون
قالوا ابنوا له بنيانا
فالقوه في الجحيم
فارادوا به كيدا فجعلناهم
الاسفلين
وقال اني ذاهب الى ربي سيهدين
رب هب لي من الصالحين
فبشرناه
بغلام حليم
فلما بلغ معه السعي قال يا بني يا بني اني
ارى يا بني اني ارى في المنام اني اذبحك
فانظر ماذا تراه قال يا ابت افعل ما تؤمر
ستجدني ان شاء الله من الصابرين
فلما
اسلم ما له للجبين
وناديناه ان يا ابراهيم قد صدقت الرؤيا
انا كذلك نجزي المحسنين
ان هذا لهو البلاء المبين
وفديناه بذبح عظيم
وتركنا عليه في الاخرين سلام
سلام على ابراهيم
كذلك نجزي المحسنين
انه من عبادنا المؤمنين
وبشرناه باسحاق نبيا من الصالحين
وباركنا عليه وعلى اسحاق
ومن ذريتهما
محسن
وظالم لنفسه
ومن ذريتهما
محسن
وظالم لنفسه مبين
ولقد مننا على موسى وهارون
ونجيناهما
وقومهما من الكرب العظيم
ونصرناهم فكانوا هم الغالبين
واتينا ناهما الكتاب المستبين
وهديناهما الصراط المستقيم
وتركنا عليهما في الاخرين
سلام على موسى وهارون
انا
كذلك نجزي المحسنين
انهما
من عبادنا المؤمنين
وان الياس لمن المرسلين
اذ قال لقومه الا تتقون
اتدعون بعلا وتذرون احسن الخالقين
الله ربكم وربائكم
الاولين
فكذبوه فانهم لمحضرون
الا عباد الله المخلصين
وتركنا عليه في الاخرين سلام على الياسين
انا
كذلك نجزي المحسنين
انه من عبادنا المؤمنين
وان لوطا لمن المرسلين
اذ نجيناه واهله اجمعين
الا عجوزا
في الغابرين
ثم دمرنا
الاخرين
وانكم لتمرون عليهم مصبحين
وبال الليل
افلا تعقلون
وان يونس لمن المرسلين
اذ ابق الى الفلك المشحون فساهم فكان من
المضحضين
فالتقمه الحوت وهو مليم
فلولا انه
كان من المسبحين
للبث في بطنه الى يوم يبعثون
فنبذناه بالعراء
وهو سقيم
وانبتنا
عليه شجره
عليه شجره من يقطين
وارسلناه الى 100 ال او يزيدون
فامنوا فمتعناهم
الى حين
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سجود
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقم قيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
فاستفتهم
ربك البنات ولهم البنون
ام خلقنا الملائكه
اناثا
وهم شاهدون
الا انهم من افكهم ليقولون ولد الله
وانهم
لكاذبون
اصطفى البنات على البنين
ما لكم كيف تحكمون
افلا تذكرون
ام لكم سلطان مبين
فاتوا بكتاب كتابكم ان كنتم صادقين
وجعلوا بينه وبين الجنه
نسبا ولقد علمت الجنه انهم لمحضرون
سبحان الله عما يصفون
الا عباد الله المخلصين
فانكم وما تعبدون ما انتم عليه بفاتنين
الا من هو صال الجحيم
وما منا الا له مقام معلوم
وانا لنحن الصافون
وانا لنحن المسبحون
وان كانوا ليقولون لو ان عندنا
لو ان عندنا ذكرا من الاولين
لكنا عباد الله المخلصين
فكفروا به فسوف يعلمون
ولقد سبقت كلمتنا لعبادنا المرسلين
انهم
لهم المنصور
ون
جندنا لهم الغالبون
فتولى فتولى عنهم حتى حين وابصرهم فسوف
يبصرون
افبعذابنا
يستعجلون
فاذا نزل بساحتهم فساء
صباح المنذرين
وتولى عنهم حتى حين
وابصر فسوف يبصرون
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
بسم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
صاد
والقران ذي الذكر بل الذين كفروا في عزه
وشقاق
كم اهلكنا من قبلهم من قرن فنادوا فنادوا
ولا تحين مناص وعجبوا ان جاءهم
منذر
منهم
وقال الكافرون هذا ساحر كذاب
اجعل الالهه الها واحدا
ان هذا لشيء ان هذا لشيء عجاب
وانطلق الملا منهم ان امشوا واصبروا على
الهتكم
ان هذا لشيء يراد
ما سمعنا بهذا في المله الاخره ان هذا الا
اختلاق
اانزل
عليه الذكر من بيننا بل هم في شك من ذكري
بل لما يذوقوا عذاب
ام
خزائن رحمه ربك كالعزيز الوهاب
ام لهم ملك السماوات والارض وما بينهما
فليرتقوا في الاسباب
جند ما هنالك مهزوم من الاحزاب
كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح
وعاد وفرعون ذو الاوتاد
وثمود وقوم لوط واصحاب الايكه اولئك
الاحزاب
ان كل الا كذب الرسل فحق عقاب
وما ينظر هؤلاء الا صيحه واحده الا صيحه
واحده ما لها من فوا
ق وقالوا ربنا عجل لنا قطنا قبل يوم
الحساب
اصبر على ما يقولون واذكر عبدنا داوود
واذكر عبدنا داوود ذا الايد انه اواب
انا سخرنا الجبال معه يسبحن بالعشي
والاشراق
والطير محشوره
كل له اواب
وشددنا ملكه واتيناه
الحكمه واتيناه
الحكمه وفصل الخطاب
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
ضب
الله اكبر
الله
اكثر
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وهل اتاك نبا الخصم اذ تسوروا المحراب
اذ دخلوا على داوود ففزع منهم قالوا لا
تخف خصمان بغى بعضنا على بعض فاحكم بيننا
فاحكم بيننا بالحق ولا تشط واهدنا الى
سواء الصراط
ان هذا اخي له 99
نعجه ولي نعجه واحده فقال فقال قال
اكفنيها
فقال اكفنيها وعزني في الخطاب
قال لقد ظلمك بسؤال معجك الى نعاجه
وان كثيرا من الخلطاء
ليبغي بعضهم على بعض الا
الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات وقليل
وظن داوود انما
فتناه
فاستغفر ربه وخر راكعا
واناب
الله اكبر
سجده ودين الذي خلق
فغفرنا له ذلك وان له عندنا لزلفا وحسن
ماب
يا داوود انا جعلناك خليفه
في الارض فاحكم بين الناس فاحكم بين الناس
بالحق ولا تتبع الهوى
ولا تتبع الهوى فيضلك عن سبيل الله
ان الذين يضلون عن سبيل الله لهم عذاب
شديد
لهم عذاب شديد بما نسوا يوم الحساب
وما خلقنا السماء والارض وما بينهما باطلا
ظن الذين كفروا فويل للذين كفروا من النار
ام نجعل الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
كالمفسدين في الارض ام نجعل المتقين
كالفجار
كتاب انزلناه اليك مبارك ليدبروا اياته
وليتذكر اولو الالباب
ووهبنا لداوود سليمان نعم العبد انه اوابه
اذ عرض عليه بالعشي الصافنات الجياد
فقال اني احببت حب
الخير عن ذكر ربي حتى توارت بالحجاب
ردوها علي ردوها علي فطفق مسحا بالسوق
والاعناق
ولقد فتنا سليمان والقينا على كرسيه جسدا
والقينا على كرسيه جسدا
ثم ناب
قال رب اغفر لي وهب لي ملكا لا ينبغي لاحد
من بعدي
انك انت الوهاب
فسخرنا له الريح تجري بامره رخاء
حيث اصاب
والشياطين كل بناء
وغواص
واخرين مقرنين في الاصفاد
هذا عطاؤنا
فمن او امسك او امسك بغير حساب
وان له عندنا لزلفا وحسن ماب
واذكر عبدنا ايوب اذ نادى ربه
اذ نادى ربه اني مسني الشيطان بنصب وعذاب
اركض برجلك اركض برجلك هذا مغتسل
بارد وشراب
ووهبنا له اهله ومثلهم
معهم ومثلهم معهم رحمه
وذكرى لاولي الالباب
وخذ بيدك ضغفا فاضرب به فاضرب به ولا تحنث
انا وجدناه صابرا نعم العبد انه اواب
واذكر عبدنا ابراهيم واسحاق ويعقوب
واذكر ذكر عبادنا ابراهيم
واذكر عبادنا ابراهيم واسحاق ويعقوب اولي
الايدي والابصار
انا
اخلصناهم
بخالصه
ذكر الدار
وانهم
عندنا لمن المصطفين
الاخيار
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
لاكار
اسماعيل
[Silence]
لنهايه القيام الليله
القيام الليله
الفجر
[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
واذكر اسماعيل واليسع وذا الكفل وكل من
الاخيار
هذا ذكر وان للمتقين لحسن ماب
جنات عدن مفتحه لهم الابواب
متكئين فيها يدعون فيها بفاكهه كثيره
وشراب
وعندهم قاصرات الطرف اتراب
هذا ما توعدون ليوم الحساب
ان هذا لرزقنا ما له من نفاد
هذا وان للطاغين لشر ماب
جهنم يصلونها فبئس المهاد
هذا فليذوقوه حميم وغساق
واخر من شكله ازواج
هذا فوج مقت وتحم معكم لا مرحبا بهم انهم
صالوا النار
قالوا بل انتم لا مرحبا بكم انتم قدمتموه
لنا فبئس القرار
قالوا ربنا من قدم لنا هذا فزده عذابا
ضعفا في النار
وقالوا ما لنا لا نرى رجالا كن انا نعدهم
من الاشرار
اتخذناهم سخريا ام زاغت عنهم الابصار
ان ذلك لحق تخاصم اهل النار
قل انما انا منذر وما من اله الا الله
الواحد القهار
رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما العزيز
الغفار
قل هو نبا عظيم انتم عنه معرضون
ما كان لي من علم بالملا الاعلى اذ
يختصمون
ان ان يوحى الي الا انما انا نذير مبين
اذ قال ربك للملائكه
اني خالق بشرا من طين فاذا سويته
ونفخت فيه من روحي فقعوا له ساجدين
فسجد الملائكه
كلهم اجمعون الا ابليس استكبر وكان من
الكافرين قال يا ابليس ما منعك ان تسجد
لما خلقت بيدي
قال يا ابليس ما منعك ان تسجد لما خلقت
بيدي
استكبرت ام كنت من العال ين قال انا خير
منه خلقتني من نار وخلقته من طين
قال فاخرج منها فانك رجيم وان عليك لعنتي
الى يوم الدين قال رب فانظرني الى يوم
يبعثون قال فانك من المنظرين الى يوم
الوقت المعلوم
قال فبعزتك لاغوينهم
اجمعين الا عبادك منهم المخلصين قال فالحق
والحق اقول
لاملان جهنم منك وممن تبعك منهم اجمعين
قل ما اسالكم عليه من اجر وما انا من
المتكلفين
ان هو الا ذكر للعالمين
ولتعلم
نباه بعد حين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تنزيل الكتاب من
الله العزيز الحكيم انا انزلنا اليك
الكتاب بالحق فاعبد الله مخلصا له الدين
الا لله الدين الخالص والذين اتخذوا من
دونه اولياء جاء ما نعبدهم الا ليقربونا
الى الله زلفا ان الله يحكم بينهم فيما هم
فيه يختلفون
ان الله لا يهدي من هو كاذب كفار
لو اراد الله ان يتخذ ولدا لاصطفى مما
يخلق ما يشاء
سبحانه هو الله الواحد القهار
خلق السماوات والارض بالحق يكور الليل على
النهار ويكور النهار على الليل وسخر الشمس
والقمر كل يجري لاجل مسمى
الا هو العزيز الغفار
خلقكم من نفس واحده ثم جعل منها زوجها
وانزل لكم من الانعام ثمانيه ازواج
يخلقكم في بطون امهاتكم
خلقا من بعد خلق في ظلمات ثلاث
ذلكم الله ربكم له الملك لا اله الا هو
فانا تصرفون
ان تكفروا فان الله غني عنكم ولا يرضى
لعباده الكفر ان تشكروا يرضه لكم ولا تزر
وازره وزر اخرى ثم الى ربكم مرجعكم
فينبئكم بما كنتم تعملون
انه عليم
بذات الصدور
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واذا مس الانسان ضر دعا ربه منيبا اليه ثم
اذا خوله منه نعمه نسي ما كان يدعو اليه
من قبل وجعل لله اندادا ليضل عن سبيله
واذا مس الانسان ضر دعا ربه منيبا اليه ثم
اذا خوله نعمه منه نسي ما كان يدعو اليه
من قبل وجعل لله اندادا
وجعل لله اندادا ليضل عن سبيله قل تمتع
بكفرك قليلا انك من اصحاب النار
امن هو قانت اناء
الليل ساجدا وقائما
يحذر الاخره ويرجو رحمه ربه قل هل يستوي
الذين يعلمون والذين لا يعلمون
انما يتذكر اولو الالباب
قل يا عبادي الذين امنوا اتقوا ربكم
للذين احسنوا في هذه الدنيا حسنه وارض
الله واسعه انما يوفى الصابرون اجرهم بغير
حساب
قل اني امرت ان اعبد الله مخلصا له الدين
وامرت لان اكون اول المسلمين
قل اني اخاف ان عصيت ربي عذاب يوم عظيم
عظيم
قل الله اعبد مخلصا له ديني فاعبدوا ما
شئتم من دونه قل ان الخاسرين الذين خسروا
انفسهم واهليهم يوم القيامه الا ذلك هو
الخسران المبين
لهم من فوقهم ظلل من النار ومن تحتهم ظلل
ذلك يخوف الله به عباده يا عبادي فاتقون
والذين اجتنبوا الطاغوت ان يعبدوها وانبوا
الى الله لهم البشرى فبشر عباد
الذين يستمعون القول فيتبعون احسنه اولئك
الذين هداهم الله واولئك هم اولو الالباب
افمن افما
افمن حق عليه كلمه العذاب
افانت تنقذ من في النار
لكن الذين اتقوا ربهم لهم غرف من فوقهم
غرف مبنيه تجري من تحتهم الانهار تجري من
تحتها الانهار
لكن الذين اتقوا ربهم لهم غرف لهم غرف
لهم غرف من فوقها غرف مبنيه تجري من تحتها
الانهار
وعد الله لا يخلف الله الميعاد
الم تر ان الله انزل من السماء
ماء فسلكه ينابيع في الارض ثم يخرج به
زرعا مختلفا الوانه ثم يهيج فتراه مصفرا
ثم يجعله حطاما ان في ذلك لذكرى لاولي
الالباب
افمن شرح الله صدره للاسلام فهو على نور
من ربه فويل للقاسيه قلوبهم من ذكر الله
اولئك في ضلال مبين
الله نزل احسن الحديث كتابا متشابها
مثانيه تقشعر منه جلود الذين يخشون ربهم
ثم تلين جلودهم وقلوبهم الى ذكر الله
ذلك هدى الله يهدي به من يشاء
ومن يضلل الله فما له هاد
افمن يتقي بوجهه سوء العذاب يوم القيامه
وقيل للظالمين ذوقوا ما كنتم تكسبون
كذب الذين من قبلهم فاذاق كذب الذين من
قبلهم فاتاهم العذاب من حيث لا يشعرون
فاذاقهم الله الخزي في الحياه الدنيا
ولعذاب الاخره اكبر لو كانوا يعلمون
ولقد ضربنا للناس في هذا القران من كل مثل
لعلهم يتذكرون
قرانا عربيا غير ذي عوج لعلهم يتقون
ضرب الله مثلا رجلا فيه شركاء متشاكسون
ورجلا سلما لرجل
هل يستويان مثلا الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون
انك ميت وانهم ميتون
ثم انكم يوم القيامه عند ربكم تختصمون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
فمن اظلم ممن كذب على الله وكذب بالصدق اذ
جاءه
اليس في جهنم مثواى للكافرين
والذي جاء بالصدق وصدق به اولئك هم
المتقون لهم ما يشاءون عند ربهم ذلك جزاء
المحسنين
ذلك جزاء المحسنين ليكفر الله عنهم اسوا
الذي عملوا ويجزي زيهم اجرهم باحسن الذي
كانوا يعملون
اليس الله بكاف عبده ويخوفونك بالذين من
دونه ومن يضلل الله فما له من هاد
ومن يهدي الله فما له من مضل
اليس الله بعزيز ذي انتقام
ولئن سالتهم من خلق السماوات والارض
ليقولن الله
قل افرايتم ما تدعون من دون الله ان
ارادني الله بضر هل هن كاشفات ضره
ان ارادني الله بضر هل هن كاشفات ضره او
ارادني برحمه هل هن ممسكات رحمته
قل حسبي الله عليه يتوكل
المتوكلون
قل يا قوم اعملوا على مكانتكم اني عامل
فسوف تعلمون
من فسوف تعلمون
[Arabic recitation]
انا انزلنا عليك الكتاب للناس بالحق فمن
اهتدى فل لنفسه ومن ضل فانما يضل عليها
وما انت عليهم بوكيل
الله يتوفى الانفس حين موتها والتي لم تمت
في منامها فيمسك التي قضى عليها الموت
ويرسل الاخرى الى اجل مسمى ان في ذلك
لايات لقوم يتفكرون
ام اتخذوا من دون الله شفعاء
قل اولو كانوا لا يملكون شيئا ولا يعقلون
قل لله الشفاعه جميعا له ملك السماوات
والارض ثم اليه ترجعون
واذا ذكر الله وحده اشمازت قلوب الذين لا
يؤمنون بالاخره
واذا ذكر الذين من دونه اذا هم يستبشرون
قل اللهم
فاطر السماوات والارض عالم الغيب والشهاده
انت تحكم بين عبادك فيما كانوا فيه
يختلفون
ولو ان للذين ظلموا ما في الارض جميعا
ومثله معه لافتدوا به من سوء العذاب يوم
القيامه
وبد بدى لهم من الله ما لم يكونوا يحتسبون
وبدى لهم سيئات ما كسبوا وحاق بهم ما
كانوا به يستهزئون
فاذا مس الانسان ضر دعانا
ثم اذا خولناه نعمه منا قال انما اوتيته
على علم بل هي فتنه لكن اكثرهم لا يعلمون
قد قالها الذين من قبلهم فما اغنى عنهم ما
كانوا يكسبون
فاصابهم سيئات ما كسبوا والذين ظلموا من
هؤلاء
سيصيبهم سيئات ما كسبوا وما هم بمعجزين
اولم يعلموا ان الله يبسط الرزق لمن يشاء
ويقدر ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يؤمنون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
الله بر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل يا عبادي الذين اسرفوا على انفسهم لا
تقنطوا من رحمه الله
ان الله يغفر الذنوب جميعا انه هو الغفور
الرحيم
وانيبوا الى ربكم واسلموا له من قبل ان
ياتيكم العذاب ثم لا تنصرون
واتبعوا احسن ما انزل اليكم من ربكم من
قبل ان ياتي يتيكم العذاب بغته وانتم لا
تشعرون
ان تقول نفس يا حسر على ما فرطت في جنب
الله وان كنت لمن الساخرين
او تقول لو ان الله هداني لكنت من المتقين
او تقول حين ترى العذاب لو ان كره فاكون
من المحسنين
بلى قد جاءتك
اياتي فكذبت بها واستكبرت وكنت من
الكافرين
ويوم القيامه ترى الذين كذبوا على الله
وجوههم
مسوده
اليس في جهنم مثواى للمتكبرين
وينجي الله الذين اتقوا بمفازتهم لا يمسهم
السوء سوء ولا هم يحزنون
الله خالق كل شيء وهو على كل شيء وكيل له
مقاليد السماوات والارض والذين كفروا
بايات الله اولئك هم الخاسرون
قل افغير الله تامروني
اعبد ايها الجاهل
ولقد اوحي اليك والى الذين من قبلك لئن
اشركت ليحبطن عملك ولتكونن من الخاسرين
بل الله فاعبد وكن من الشاكرين
وما قدروا الله حق قدره والارض جميعا
قبضته يوم القيامه والسماوات مطويات
بيمين
سبحانه وتعالى عما يشركون
ونفخ في الصور فصعق من في السماوات ومن في
الارض الا من شاء الله
ثم نفخ فيه اخرى فاذا هم قيام ينظرون
واشرقت الارض بنور ربها ووضع الكتاب وجيء
بالنبيين والشهداء
وقضي بينهم بالحق وهم لا يظلمون
ووفيت كل نفس ما عملت وهو اعلم بما يفعلون
وسيق الذين كفروا الى جهنم
زمرا حتى اذا جاؤوها
فتحت ابوابها وقال لهم خزنتها
الم ياتكم رسل منكم
وقال لهم خزنتها الم ياتكم رسل منكم يتلون
عليكم ايات ربكم وينذرونكم
لقاء
يومكم هذا قالوا بلى ولكن حقت كلمه العذاب
على الكافرين
قيل ادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين فيها فبئس
مثوى المتكبرين
وسيق الذين اتقوا ربهم الى الجنه زمرا حتى
اذا جاؤوها
وفتحت ابوابها وقال لهم خزنتها سلام عليكم
سلام عليكم طبتم فادخلوها خالدين
وقالوا الحمد لله الذي صدق قنا وعده
واورثنا الارض نتبوا من الجنه حيث نشاء
فنعم اجر العاملين
وترى الملائكه
حافين
من حول العرش
يسبحون بحمد ربهم وقضي بينهم بالحق وقيل
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
make الشفع والوتر
20 days always stop at 9:45
that we are in the last 10 as promed as
as I mention to you before we going to
be adding a coule of extra pages each
night so that we can finish the Quran on
the 29th
and because it's the last
15 minut are
because
additation
and length of prayer we add another
minut to the break between the prayers
right between the
which is where really gets its name from
right so we have a 10 minut break as
opposed to a four or five minut break
before so just you know heads
[Silence]
‏here.
كبار اسمك
خيرك اعذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهد اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والضحى والليل اذا سجى ما ود ودعك ربك وما
قلى ولا الاخره خير لك من الاولى
ولسوف يعطيك ربك فترضى
الم يجدك يتيما
فاوى
ووجدك ضالا
فهدى
ووجدك عائلا
فاغنى
فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر
واما السائل
فلا تنهر
واما
بنعمه ربك فحدث
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد اياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
الم نشرح لك صدرك ووضعنا عنك وزرك الذي
انقض
ظهرك
ورفعنا لك ذكرك
فان مع العسر يسرا ان
مع العسر يسرا
فاذا فرغت فانصب
والى ربك فارغب
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اشهد ان
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه رحمه الله
make صلاه now
quick
for us to say amين with behind the as
makes his
what am
امين اسم فعل امر يقول علماء الاعتقاد اسم
فعل دعاء
اللهم استجب
الله
make
امين
اللهم
[Silence]
الله
امين لو قال الانسان حقا او صدقا كما يقول
بعض الناس فيجوز يصح والا فالافضل للتامين
في كل شيء
الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرح
يد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سميع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي
ولا يقضى عليك
وانه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم لك الحمد حتى ترضى ولك الحمد اذا
رضيت
ولك الحمد بعد الرضا ولك الحمد على كل حال
لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض لك
الحمد انت قيوم السماوات والارض يا رحمن
الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما
اللهم اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو
امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به
نفسك او انزلته
على احد من خلقك
او استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جاهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسي نا وعلمنا الحكمه منه
اللهم اجعل القران العظيم شافعا مشفعا لنا
حجه لنا لا علينا
وجعلنا من اهله اهلك يا ربنا
اللهم اننا نتبتل اليك
ونتوسل اليك
ونرفع اكفنا
اليك
يا حي يا كريم
يا من يستحيي من عباده اذا ما رفعوا اليك
اكفهم
ان تردها خائبه
اللهم
اننا نرفع اليك اكفنا
نرفع اليك اكفنا متبتلين
اليك
متوسلين
فقراء
اليك
لما غفرت لنا ربنا اغفر لنا
ربنا ونغفر لنا
ربنا لا تدع لنا في هذا الجمع ذنبا الا
غفرته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا مسكينا الا
اعطيته ولا مريضا الا شفيته اللهم
اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك كمنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا
اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين
فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
ربنا ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار
ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا وذرياتنا
قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين
اماما
وجعلنا للمتقين
اللهم انا نعوذ بك من جهد البلاء
ودرك الشقاء
وسوء القضاء
وشماته الاعداء
اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه
في غزه وفلسطين
وفي السودان
وفي كشمير
وفي كل مكان
اللهم انصرهم
على عدوهم
واجعلهم على عدوهم ظاهرين
قاهرين
عا ين
عزيزين
منصورين
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
اللهم اننا نجعلك في نحورهم
ونعوذ بك من شرورهم
اللهم
زلزل اركانهم
وصدع بنيانهم
واقتل اجنادهم
واقذف الهلع والفزع والرعب في قلوبهم
واجعل احياءهم في ذل وهوان
واجعل احياءهم في ذل وهوان حيث حلوا واجعل
قتلاهم في النيران
اللهم انتقم قم لعبادك
اللهم انتقم لعبادك اللهم انتقم لاتباع
نبيك واهل لا
اله الا الله
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اشهد ان
اشهد
صل على
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
ركع
‏Thums up. தேங்க்யூ